Die sogenannte Sintigraphie der Schildrüse ist eine spezielle Untersuchungsmethode, bei der wir die Funktion der Schildrüse sehen können.
Sie haben eine vergrößerte Schildrüse und wir möchten auch eine Störung der Funktion der Schildrüse, also eine sogenannte Über- oder Unterfunktion, untersuchen.
Nun, wir möchten sehen, ob es Knoten in der Schildrüse gibt. Das ist wichtig, um herauszufinden, ob dies behandelt werden muss oder nicht.
Wir haben im Ultraschall einen Knoten gesehen, den wir genauer beurteilen möchten.
Haben Sie eine Allergie gegen Jod oder irgendwelche anderen Allergien?
Wir geben Ihnen einen radioaktiven Stoff. Die Menge ist aber sehr gering und schadet dem Körper nicht.
Sie bekommen den Stoff über eine Wehne am Arm. Normalerweise wird dies über den Urin innerhalb von einem Tag wieder ausgeschieden.
Deshalb ist es wichtig, dass Sie nach der Untersuchung viel trinken und wir eventuell auch die näheren Funktionen im Labor einmal bei Ihnen bestimmen.
Die Untersuchung ist vollkommen schmerzfrei, dauert etwa eine Stunde und Sie sollten am Tag der Untersuchung längeren Körperkontakt, also engen Körperkontakt mit Kindern oder auch schwangeren Frauen, falls Sie das zufällig haben, vermeiden.
Die Strahlenbelastung ist zwar sehr gering, aber natürlich sollte in diesen Situationen jede unnötige Strahlung vermieden werden.
Außerdem, wie gesagt, sollten Sie nach der Untersuchung viel Wasser trinken, damit dieses Mittel möglichst schnell über die Nähern ausgeschieden wird.
Wenn Patienten nun fragen, warum lässt sich das mit einer Laboruntersuchung nicht auch erledigen, dann sagen Sie, also mit dem Labor können wir nur die allgemeine Funktion der Schilddröse beurteilen,
aber nicht, ob es Knoten gibt oder andere Veränderungen und was in diesen Knoten passiert.
Solche Knoten können verschiedene Ursachen haben und das können wir mit dieser Untersuchung recht gut beurteilen.